essant and Dr Sofa was like, well, what was
it?
They explained that they went and sat with
him.
They listened to him.
They realized that his pain made sense.
It was hard for him to see it in the throws
of his depression actually have perfectly
understandable causes in his life.
One of them figured if we bought this guy
a cow, he could become a dairy farmer.
He wouldn't have to work in the rice.
He wouldn't be in this position.
That was screwing him up so much.
So they bought him account.
Within a couple of weeks, his crying stopped.
Within a month, his depression was gone.
They said to doctor, to someone filled the
Cambodians.
So you see Dr Cow.
That was an antidepressant.
That's what you mean right now.
If you'd been raised to think about depression
the way that most of us worry that it's just
a problem in your brain, that sounds like
a bad joke, right?
I went to my doctor for an antidepressant.
She gave me a cow, but what those Cambodian
doctors knew intuitively from that individual
unscientific anecdote is what the leading
medical body in the world, the World Health
Organization has been trying to tell us for
years.
If you're depressed, if you're anxious, you're
not crazy, you're not weak.
You're not in the main a machine with broken
parts.
Your human being with unmet needs and what
you need is love and practical help to get
those needs met.
This is why the leading doctor at the United
Nations on this topic, in their official statement
for World Health Day said a few years ago,
we need to talk less about chemical imbalances
and more about the imbalances in the way we
live, and there's not to say there aren't
very real biological contributions.
There are.
It's not to say that drugs don't give some
relief to some people they do.
They gave relief to me for awhile, but precisely
because this problem goes much deeper than
our biology.
The solutions need to go much deeper too,
and I went to lots of places in the world
from Colombia to an Amish village in Indian,
Indiana to Cambodia where people didn't need
to be told that, where they knew intuitively
that depression is a signal, right?
It depression is not a malfunction.
The way that we, we've been taught to think
about it in this culture for the vast majority
of people is to think about depression is
effectively what we're told as a story.
Think about what my doctor taught me again
with really good intentions was your depression
is like a glitch in a machine, right?
It's like a wiring problem in your brain,
but actually the best evidence shows is while
there are biological contributions that can
make you more sensitive and compose obstacles
to getting out.
Actually for the overwhelming majority of
depressed and anxious people.
We feel these ways, the reasons that sure
can be hard to see when you're in depression.
I know that very well.
And the actually the key is to solve the underlying
problem.
Yeah.
So let's dig into that a little bit because,
so, okay, let's put aside for a second what
we're talking about in terms of genetic predispositions,
chemical imbalances, and we'll focus kind
of on the environmental and situational.
Um, in the West there are stories about phone
usage and social media makes people anxious
and depressed.
There's situational depression after someone,
a loved one has passed away, for example,
which is really sort of a different category
in in many cases of depression.
There is the sort of involvement in the never
ending Western vulture capitalist rat race,
which can create this sort of like systemic
depression and anxiety and people.
Can you talk a little bit about what we mean
when we say at least in the modern west, the
sort of circumstances that lead to depression?
Well, I go through lots of them in my, in
my bit loss connections.
I think you've gone to a really important
point, David.
I think Sandy, actually you cover a lot on
your show brilliantly.
Part of the problem with the biological model,
right?
There is some truth in it.
There are real biological contributions to
depression, but part of what it's done is
profoundly depoliticize the pain caused by
neo-liberalism.
So what you've had is a massive increase in
depression.
I think you and I are about the same age.
How old are you, David?
I'm 35 yes.
We're about the same age or a little bit younger
than me.
And you know, all throughout our lives, depression
and anxiety have increased.
There's very strong evidence.
For example, financial insecurity causes depression,
right?
It's not rocket science.
If you'd said to my grandmother or your grandmother,
[inaudible], you think, if you think being
really stressed about money is gonna make
you more likely to become depressed.
My grandmother would have clicked me around
the ear and said, why are you wasting my time?
Right?
Asking me such stupid questions.
If you think about many of the factors in
the way we live, that increased people's depression
and anxiety.
You've seen those forces, and at the same
time you've seen, and this is not conspiracy
or anyone consciously doing this, you've seen
the rise of a story that says, oh no, your
depression isn't anything to do with all of
those things.
The fact that half of all Americans through
no fault of their own have less than $500
in savings for if a crisis comes along, which
is gonna make you really anxious and really
depressed.
I can talk about some of the science of how
we know that if you like, rather than saying
to people, well that's why you feel that way.
Your pain makes sense.
It's perfectly understandable that you feel
that way.
What we've done is tell people mysteriously,
you've all just got a chemical imbalance in
your brains around the same time as things
like inequality rise.
So I give you some specific examples of a,
of things, deep factors in the way we live
and how we can deal with them.
So I notice that lots of the people I know
who are depressed and anxious, their depression,
anxiety focuses around their work.
So start, look at what's the evidence around
this, right?
Um, uh, you gov did a really detailed, sorry,
Gallup did a really detailed study of this
in the United States.
What they found is 13% of those, one, 3% like
our jobs, most of the time, 63% of what they
called sleep working.
You don't like it, you don't hate it.
You just kind of get through it.
And 24% of people hate and fear their jobs.
It was quite struck by that 87% of people
don't like the thing they're doing most of
their waking lives.
And in fact, this thing is expanding over
more and more of our lives as, as we, you
know, we're constantly on call, started to
ask, could, could this be having some effect
on our, on our mental health.
So I learned that it was incredible.
Australian social social scientist and professor
Michael [inaudible] who made a big breakthrough
about this in the 70s so I went to interview
him and he discovered the key factor that
causes depression at work.
It's not the only one that is the key one.
If you go to work and you have low or no control
over your job, so you just got to do what
you're told, you're significantly more likely
to become depressed.
Actually, you're more likely to get sick in
almost every way and will likely die of a
heart attack or the problems.
And at first when I spoke to professor moment,
I remember actually really misunderstanding
this evidence.
So I thought he was saying, okay, you've got
this elite 13% of people at the top, you get
to have nice jobs that they control like you
and me.
Great.
They're going to be happy.
And then you've got everyone else who's condemned
to this misery.
And I thought that my family, my grandmother's
job was to clean toilets.
My Dad was a bus driver, my brother was an
Uber driver.
I was like, wait, are you saying these people
are just condemned?
And Professor Mama kept explaining to me,
it's not the work that makes you depressed.
It's being controlled at work.
And it turns out, this is me talking now,
not him.
There's an antidepressant for that.
So I went and spent a fair bit of time in,
in, in several workplaces like this, but I'll
give you an example of what I went to meet
a woman called Meredith Keough in Baltimore
and Meredith used to go to sleep every Sunday
night just to sick with anxiety.
She had an office job is, Meredith would tell
you it wasn't the worst office job in the
world.
She wasn't being bullied or harassed or anything,
but it was monotonous.
It was boring.
She was controlled.
She had no ability to use her hand mind and
Meredith couldn't bear the thought this was
going to be the next 30 years of her life.
So with her husband, Josh, she did this quite
bold thing.
And when people hear this, the thing I'm going
to think, I'm going to say, you should all
do this today, listener.
And that's, that's not what I'm saying.
It's an argument for structural change.
Josh should work in bike stores in Baltimore
since he was a teenager, you know, insecure
work, you've got no benefits.
You don't even have vacation time unless you're
post Danes to give it to you.
And one day Josh was in this bike store with
his colleagues and they ask themselves, what
does our post actually do?
Right?
They didn't hate their boss.
He was actually quite a nice bloke, but they
were like, we seem to fix all the bikes and
this other dude seems to make all the money.
They decided to set up our bike store of their
own code.
Baltimore Bicycle works that works on a different
principle.
So their place, the place that worked before,
like most people listening to this, they worked
in a corporation, right?
Very recent human invention.
And it goes back to the late 19th century.
People know how it works.
It's like a dictatorship.
You've got to obey the boss.
Sometimes the boss is nice, sometimes he's
the equivalent of Kim Jordan.
You've got no say over that.
You do what the boss tells you.
Um, they decided they were going to set up
a bike store that worked on an older American
idea.
Baltimore bicycle works is a democratic cooperative.
They don't have a boss.
They make the decisions about the business
together.
So in practice they agree most of the time,
but if they don't, they vote on it.
They share out the profits, they share out
the good tasks and the crappy tasks and no
one gets stuck with the crappy tasks.
And one of the things that was so striking
to me, spending time with the people at Baltimore
Bicycle works was totally aligned with Preston
moment's findings by the way, was how many
of them talked about how they had been depressed
and anxious before in the previous places
that weren't but were not depressed and anxious.
Now it's important to say, it's not like they
quit their jobs fixing bikes and went off
to become, I don't know, Beyonce is backing
singers or something.
Right?
They fixed bikes before they fixed bikes.
Now what's the difference?
Now they've got control over their work.
There is no reason we should be structuring
our society so that most of us are spending
most of our time in institutions that make
us feel depressed, anxious, or at the very
least less happy and satisfied.
[inaudible] every corporation should be a
democratic cooperative.
That's a big thing.
We've got to understand some of the causes
of depression that are playing out are big
in our society and culture.
One in three middle aged women in the United
States at any given time.
It's taking a chemical antidepressant to get
through the day, even more techie opioids
to deal with their pain, to get through the
day, psychological pain as well as of course
physical pain.
And some of these causes are very [inaudible].
Others are, are easier to deal with.
Um, but I think we, we've got to be honest
about how deep this crisis goes and how some
of the institutions in our society and culture
are causing that depression.
Cause at the moment what we do is we say,
you know, you've got this job where you're
humiliated, you're controlled, you can't use
your creativity in your mind and you're miserable
or there's something wrong with you.
Right?
It's so wrong in your brain.
The Krishna Murti, the great Bengali philosopher
said, it's no sign of good health to be well
adjusted to a sick society,
a Johan in the sort of limited time we have
left.
Can you talk about the things that don't work
particularly well or at least instances where
they don't.
So like for example, SSRI antidepressants,
some people overstate how well they work.
Some people also understate the how well they
work.
They work okay for some people better than
placebo to the extent that they continue taking
them and then when people stop they work a
little bit less well.
But I want to sort of have a good understanding
without over or understating the effectiveness
of different treatment modalities.
Well, I think we need to expand our idea of
what an antidepressant is.
Anything that reduces depression and anxiety
should be regarded as an antidepressant.
Yes, you are lonely.
You are significantly more likely to become
depressed.
There are programs in Britain where they got
lonely people to join gardening programs.
It was twice as effective as chemical antidepressants.
If you think life is about money and status
and showing off the things that advertising
and Instagram and everything like them, teach
us to believe you are significantly more likely
to become depressed.
When people like Professor Tim Kasser at Knox
College in Illinois did research where they
got people to meet and talk about meaningful
values, things, moments in their life, they
have actually found meaning in connection.
It caused a measurable shift in their values
away from some of these forces that cause
depression and anxiety.
In La, they banned outdoor advertising because
they could see advertising makes us depressed.
It's constantly prompting us to feel bad.
If you had a very traumatic childhood as as
I did, and you have a lot of shame about that,
uh, that is a massive factor in depression
and anxiety and Dr. Vincent Felitti and other
people that I interviewed showed.
If you give people who've had traumatic childhoods,
safe places to release that shame to see that
it wasn't their fault, they were treated badly.
Facts, a massive antidepressant, massively
reduces depression and anxiety.
So I'm in favor of a radically expanded menu
of antidepressants on that menu.
Should be chemical antidepressants.
They give some relief to some people, which
is hugely valuable.
They gave relief to me sadly for short time.
Um, but, but real relief for a time.
But that menu needs to include many more things.
There's overwhelming evidence.
This isn't my view, this isn't some cranky
view.
The World Health Organization, the leading
medical body in
the world has been warning us the years that
this overly biological model is damaging people's
health.
It tells them that pain doesn't mean anything.
If you're praying, if your story is that it's
in your biology, then that says to people
that you just feel this way cause it's like
a glitch.
But that's not true.
There are biological contributions, but we
feel this way for reasons.
Those reasons are understandable when they're
explained to people.
It's not like rocket science.
I think, for example, that list I just gave,
which is a obviously a partial list, I think
everyone listening would have nodded and gone,
well, of course, if you're lonely, if you're
taught that life is all about money.
If you've had a really traumatic childhood,
if you're controlled and humiliated at work,
you're going to be more likely to become depressed
and dealing with those problems together as
a culture will reduce depression and anxiety.
We need to restore to people a sense that
your
pain
makes sense.
We feel this way for reasons and together
we can deal with those reasons.
And one of the reasons I was really inspired
in the journey I did them a bit lost connections
is because all over the world from San Francisco
to Sydney to Sao Paolo, I saw people who were
doing that, who were understanding the deeper
causes of depression and we're fixing them
together.
But to do that, the very first thing we have
to do is we have to stop insulting these signals
by saying that a sign of weakness or a sign
of craziness or purely a biological malfunction,
and we need to start listening to these signals
because they are telling us something we really
need to hear and it's only when we honor these
signals and respect these signals that we
can begin to see the deliberating nourishing
deeper solutions.
The cows that are waiting all around us,
we've been speaking with Johann Hari who is
of course the author of the book lost connections
on covering the real causes of disease,
depression and the unexpected solutions.
Johann always great to talk to you.
Thank you.
Oh, totally.
My pleasure.
Thank you for being such a brilliant show.